il faudra s'habituer dorénavant à
l'application shopping sky le marché
virtuel de saint quentin en yvelines qui
regroupe l'ensemble des commerçants
présents sur l'agglomération dans les 12
communes de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et pour en parler
nous sommes avec didier fischer bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice président en
charge des commerces alors qu'est ce que
c'est shopping sky shops in sky c'est
une application importante évidemment
puisque elle permet pour les clients
d'avoir dans leur poche l'ensemble des
dirait des commerces de saint quentin et
pour les commerces et être en contact
effectivement d'être une boutique en
ligne en quelque sorte et être en
contact avec leurs oeufs avec leurs
clients pourquoi les douze communes ont
décidé de lancer ce marketplace est
place du marché virtuel de saint quentin
en yvelines
alors c'était une idée qui existait
depuis quelques mois mais dans le
contexte actuel vous pouvez comprendre
qu'on a accéléré le processus parce que
c'est une aide indispensable à l'heure
actuelle aux clients parlent beaucoup à
l'heure actuelle du cri comme en
collecte bien et c'est cela d'une
certaine façon c'est cela et c'est
mettre à disposition des commerçants une
application qui est une application
gratuite pour eux et qui va permettre en
principe de les aider dans la période
actuelle
concrètement comment ça va se dérouler
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent les saint quentinois qui nous
regardent
concrètement concrètement je dirais
d'ici le 20 je pense c'est le 20
novembre
l'application sera en ligne il suffira
pour eux de charger cette application
est ensuite ils n'ont plus qu'à naviguer
sur cette application choisir les
commerces dans lesquels ils souhaitent
d'une manière se rendent donne déjà dans
un premier temps d'une manière virtuelle
et ensuite d'une manière plus concrète
en allant retirer les produits qu'ils
ont ils ont acheté quelle est votre
stratégie finalement derrière le
lancement de cette application la
stratégie et c'est une stratégie dead
à l'heure actuelle au commerce de
développer aussi à terme un peu plus le
commerce en ligne
nous le voyons aujourd'hui dans la dans
le contexte de crise c'est une nécessité
absolue alors dans le contexte de crise
a peut être destinées à des
ce commerce des sociétés qui sont
fermées administrativement
mais à terme du coup c'est aussi je
suppose développer les produits locaux
tous les produits qui peuvent être
produits sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
bien sûr bien sûr ça ça aussi c'est
important cela ça aussi cette vocation
là on est là avec une je dirais une
application qui peut amener en effet ce
type de développement
dernière question quel type de produit
on peut retrouver du coup à bas tous les
produits pratiquement tous les produits
aujourd'hui les produits évidemment tous
les produits de première nécessité tout
ce qui est l'alimentaire mais pas
seulement l'alimentaire là tous les
commerces pourront en effet je dirais
participer à cette application
merci didier fischer je vous en prie
vice président en charge du commerce à
saint quentin en yvelines donc lancement
de l'application shopping sky le 20
novembre prochain